Ми в кав'ярні «Щось цікаве».
Ми відкрили її 2015 року.
Це насамперед був варіант збільшити крамничку.
Тут ще є цікаві апартаменти і ЦЕХ.
[сміється]
У нас тут мінімально приміщень,
а в ЦЕХу — багато простору.
Це новий напрямок розвитку.
Узагалі ми починали з того,
що я навчалася робити прикраси на склі.
Потім друг Роман їздив продавати це.
Ми з ним продавали.
Вона жила з подругою-однокласницею.
Вони робили дуже класні прикраси,
але самі їх не носили.
А я не займаюся виробництвом художнього скла.
Я займаюся продажем.
Потім ми їздили на різні цікаві фестивалі,
конкурси, концерти, ярмарки.
Класно поїхати на фестивалі.
Але чи люди цього хочуть?
Коли сусіди жили, усі запитували:
«Що ви це робите? Для кого?».
Ми відповідали: «Виставки, відкриття».
Вони: «Чому так шумно? Людей багато».
Ми самі запрошували прийти подивитися на подію.
Щось не дуже вони захоплювалися,
але виселилися. [сміється]
Коли я вступала, був супермодним
дизайн інтер'єру або щось схоже.
Я сама із Золочева.
Після школи мені казали:
«Ні-ні. Йди туди, де малий конкурс. Може, скло».
Я казала: «Скло? Що робити там?»
Мені відповідали: «Потім переведешся».
Але я дуже тішуся тому,
що були суперкласні викладачі,
які дозволяли експеременти:
ти і ліпиш, і плоске скло, і гутне скло було,
супербагато технік: і кольорове, і прозоре скло,
тому дуже тішуся.
Почався безмежний рівень амбіцій:
сьогодні ми хочемо магазинчик,
потім ми хочемо ще якусь галерею.
Пам'ятаю, що я приїхала додому, в Золочів,
і Рома мені дзвонить:
«Ми орендували приміщення на площі Ринок».
Я: «Щоооо?»
Я тоді ще в академії вчилася.
І думала: «Яке приміщення? Який бізнес? Що робити?»
Я повільна до чогось нового.
Це він такий швидкий.
Я казала: «Так, Романе, давай, роби!
Купимо скло, тут виставимо».
Але це був такий початок.
Коли треба було відкривати магазинчик
і написати афішу, поставити на площі Ринок,
ми подумали: «Ой, назву ж треба».
Хтось випадково сказав: «Треба щось цікаве», —
і так з'явилося «Щось цікаве».
А ЦЕХ розшифровується як
«Цікаві експеременти художників».
ЦЕХ розташований в адміністративному корпусі.
Це колись була їдальня для художників.
Тут такий великий простір.
Ми його зараз розділяємо на різні частинки.
Тут будуть дві кімнати.
Уже одна робоча — для майстер-класів.
Це буде великий лекторій з кав'ярнею.
Це виробництво ЦЕХу,
а там буде виробництво галузки  —
суто мого скляного бренду.
Це муфельна піч.
Тут температура спікання 800°.
Вона приблизно дві годинки нагрівається.
Звичайна пляшка сплюскується.
Ось такі різні форми для підставок можна робити,
можна вигини робити, можна просто плоскі.
Ми з майстер-класами різки, шліфовці пляшок
їздимо на різні корпоративи.
Технології змінюються.
Були колись звичайні вікна.
Ми надаємо їм нове життя,
але скло нема сенсу викидати.
Потім ми його пакетуємо.
Що це таке?
Ми беремо звичайне старе скло.
Так, воно неідеально рівне, неідеально чисте.
Але воно дає шумоізоляцію.
Ми на міжкімнатні стіни
ставимо його для тепло-, гідроізоляції.
І даємо друге життя тому самому склу.
Не більше, не менше.
Ми вирішили, що якщо ми займаємося склом...
Це сміття. Його дуже багато.
У нас смітник є.
Ми коли проходимо повз,
бачимо пляшку — клас, забираємо.
Ми вже так полюємо.
Коли йдемо по парку,
бачимо синю пляшку — забираємо,
усі працівники знають про це.
Я пам'ятаю, ще в академії почала спікати ці пляшки
і просто могла йти, біля смітників, і думати:
«О, клас! Форма така гарна! З неї щось вийде».
Складала, збирала.
Тут ми вчимо людей,
як робити прикраси, дзеркала, світильники.
Теж приходять молоді, ті, хто в школі вчаться.
Кажуть: «Ой я теж би вчилася зі склом працювати».
Я кажу: «Так-так, приходьте».
Те ж думали, що в майбутньому можна
відкрити мінікурс склярства,
де було б більше практики й теорія.
Усе завжди залежить від зацікавленості команди.
Хтось може постійно скаржитися,
що все погано і презент не такий.
Ми поставили вікна терміново.
Ми коли зайшли в цей об'єкт, де зараз ЦЕХ,
ще не встигли домовитися з управлінцем,
а вже вікна поставили.
Є люди, які постійно скаржаться,
а дехто щось робить.
Ми хочемо робити більший акцент на склі,
тому що скла у Львові мало,
але колись Львів був потужний
у виробництві гутного скла.
У нас єдина в Україні кафедра художнього скла.
Хочемо на цьому акцент зробити.